genau richtig lecker
[Musik]
hallo zusammen heute machen wir ein
richtig schönes klassisches Rezept
nämlich Waffeln ganz einfach ganz easy
ich schreibe euch wie immer alle ganz
genauen Mengenangaben hier unten in die
Infobox und deshalb starte ich auch
direkt mit meiner Zimmer warmen Butter
die habe ich anderthalb Stunden vorher
aus dem Kühlschrank genommen ihr könnt
übrigens bei dem Rezept ob es margarine
ist Butter oder sonst irgendwas das geht
alles ich habe ja auch ein Timer
Margarine und Teil Butter einfach weil
ich es verbrauchen wollte gibt es hier
in die Schüssel meiner Küchenmaschine
ihr könnt auch ein Handrührgerät
benutzen wenn jetzt keine Küchenmaschine
da habt da gebe ich Zucker rein und
Vanilleextrakt und dann schlage ich das
zusammen mit meinem Rührhaken mit der
Gummilippe 3 Minuten lang schön cremig
[Musik]
so ich habe danach im Anschluss
nacheinander die Eier mit dazu gerührt
erst hat man das Gefühl es verbindet
sich nie aber dann einfach dranbleiben
und dann verbindet das nicht so und
jetzt nehmen wir uns die trockenen
Zutaten einfach nur Backpulver und Mehl
da könntet ihr jetzt ich habe ganz
normales Mehl Typ 405 genommen ihr könnt
auch Dinkelmehl Typ 630 nehmen das wäre
an der Stelle auch kein Problem ich
verrühre das nur vorab miteinander damit
es sich besser verbindet und jetzt liebe
ich das dazu was immer mal sein kann
dass man durch Lagerung etc einfach
mehlklumpen hat also Sieb ich das jetzt
zur Masse und gebe quasi mittendrin bzw
zwischendurch auch schon die lauwarme
Milch mit dazu
[Musik]
so die Masse ist jetzt fertig und wenn
ihr wie gesagt Milch und Mehlmasse so
ein bisschen nacheinander dazu gibt dann
verbindet sich das auch gut jetzt ist
mir ein Fehler unterlaufen ich habe
nämlich die Prise Salz vergessen jetzt
denkt euch wahrscheinlich Nachkommen nur
die Prise Salz was soll die schon
anstellen aber die macht halt noch mal
einen schönen also die unterstreicht
noch mal den süßen Geschmack deswegen
habe ich das jetzt hier noch mal dazu
gegeben oder das kurz unter und dann ist
die Masse auch schon fertig und ich hole
jetzt einmal das Waffeleisen und wir
können ausbacken
so ich backe hier schon mal meine
belgischen Waffeln aus sie können
natürlich die Form nehmen die ihr
möchtet ich gebe immer gern
zwischendurch ein bisschen von meinem
backtrennspray dazu so und dann ähm
einfach also nicht zu viel Tage sollte
jetzt nicht überquillen einfach den Teig
einfüllen und dann für ein paar Minuten
backen und dann sind wir auch schon
fertig dazu passt er jetzt alles
mögliche an Toppings wenn ihr möchtet
kann ich euch mal so einen Topping Video
machen habt ihr da Interesse dran
schreibt gerne mal in die Kommentare
Schokosoße sollte Karamellsoße oder was
auch immer geht sind natürlich heiße
Kirschen oder einfach ganz klassisch
Puderzucker richtig fettes war
eigentlich ich liebe es wenn es einfach
so so perfekt aussieht
dafür dass Set also wir haben für das
Set noch
Haselnusscreme drüber drizzeln lassen
deswegen probiere ich das direkt mal ich
habe auch richtig Lust auf
pistaziencreme heute also wie bietet
sich das so an dass du einfach Cremes
drüber machen
zehn Stück rausgekommen ihr könnt die
Cremes immer bei 600 oder 900 Watt für
ein paar Sekunden in der Mikrowelle
erwärmen dann können diese richtig schön
essen lassen ja einfach reinhauen
richtig lecker kommt der
Vanillegeschmack durch geil
ich habe keine Buttermilch drin es gibt
ganz bekannte Rezepte mit
buttermilchwaffeln aber ich finde man
hat nicht immer Buttermilch zu Hause und
daher mein Rezept mit normalen Milch die
eigentlich immer jeder da hat ne ich
finde es richtig geil ich kann mir das
jetzt noch mal mit einem geilen
Cappuccino so einen geilen Counter
machen geil gesagt habe gerade im Winter
ich finde es richtig geil im geilen
Cappuccino oh mega also ich sage es gibt
Klassiker mit ähm mit mit heißen
Kirschen die creams sind einfach noch
mal next level also unbedingt nach ich
würde das auf jeden Fall nachmachen
Rezept kann man nicht viel falsch machen
schmeckt immer mit gut geht immer es
einfach macht's nach und abonniert den
Kanal wenn es noch nicht gemacht
also da gerne auch einen Kommentar wenn
du willst kannst du das Video beenden
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]
mich noch einmal klassischer Gesicht